[Musique]
du harcèlement c'est un mot qui est très
fort évidemment il ya des querelles
entre candidats on le voit à l'antenne
voilà il ya beaucoup de turenne
maintenant dire que c'est du harcèlement
je suis je ne pense pas non
en aucun cas je le dis bien ici la
production me demande d'harceler des
gens d'accord et en aucun cas moi
d'accord j'accepterai si on me demandait
d'harceler des gens oui et à l'alcool
oui comme je voulais dire sur le gâteau
il ya un verre d'alcool par soir par
contre il a maintenant à tomber il y en
a qui doit être ouvert mais
effectivement il ya des candidats à
faire rentrer de l'alcool donc son cours
de programme dans leurs valises mais
ferme je ferme les yeux il ya l'or jaune
pour e on et des responsables en il y en
a on a entre 25 et 30 ans non mais on
est responsables ne veulent pas ils
veulent ni n'ont pas envie de fouiller
nos valises il ya de la drogue
mais alors c'est encore une fois il ya
de la drogue non c'est parce que je te
dis non c'est exactement le même
discours que j'ai eu la d1 fois que tu
venu sur ce plateau d'accord et
peut-être qu'il ya de la drogue c'est
possible moi j'incite à quiconque qui a
vécu j'ai réellement d'accord ou qui a
vu quelqu'un prendre de la drogue devant
lui allait porter plainte
il ya aussi l'amour est venu j'ai une
question à poser répondez-moi flash oui
oui est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un
candidat même si ça n'est pas été amené
par la prod prendre de la drogue dans
une bd alors je vais l'aider je vais
bien là
honnêteté j'ai jamais vu deux candidats
de prendre de cocaïne effectivement ça
m'est arrivé de voir un candidat fumer
un joint turcot hommage d'accord voilà
vous en voulez la voix vérité moi je je
je je voulais bien que moody's avait ça
fait disons alors gg je suis pas un mec
parfait loin de là mais ça fait dix ans
depuis que j'ai dans l'altérité que je
me bats guerre contre la cocaïne
d'accord ça fait dix ans que si je vois
un candidat de télé réalité donc vous en
avez vu un pourquoi non si je vois en
bannissant weng li si on refait le monde
si je vois un candidat d'accord je le
dis à la production si je veux voyager
aux quatre évêques ça veut dire que
l'hexagone est complètement faux sur
l'altercation qui a pu se passer en ou
raphaël aujourd'hui mois et angel s'est
complètement quand elle parlait du
harceleur va pas l'aider net par mois
tous d'accord maintenant je veux
m'expliquer ça fait nous on n'a pas pris
une fois la parole sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui d'accord ni ma femme ni moins
d'accord ça fait 10
quinze jours que j'entends que j'aurais
été violent que j'aurais été que je
l'aurait harcelée d'accord je vais vous
dire ça fait dix ou quinze jours qu'on a
pris un avocat
dix ou quinze jours que notre avocat
nous demande de se taire on a demandé à
la production par le biais de notre
avocat les images de 19h à minuit de ce
qui s'est passé lors de cette soirée
pour justement prouvé que je ne suis pas
en tort calandre rogge
oui mais de cannabis pas de pas de coca
et moi j'ai jamais vu je n'ai jamais
bien voilà d'alcool oui ce sont les
candidats qui l'amène louis harcèlement
vous dit non c'est plein soit la note la
voilà mais non merci
mais moi je vais vous dire sans
isolement que par angel elle dit qu'elle
a été isolée suite à cette altercation
pour sa sécurité parce que on allait
être violente
moi j'ai envie de vous dire en fait elle
a été mise en isolement oui et vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'elle avait
consommé donc elle avait bu elle avait
bu de l'alcool et en tant que vous savez
qu'on est quand même passé on est
employé
on est on est sûr si on a un contrat de
travail à partir du moment où on est en
état d'ébriété sur un lieu de travail
que fait le rempailleur il nous met en
isolement non pas pour ça c'est alors
oui pour sa sécurité muffat sécurité de
quoi il ya une piscine
il ya des escaliers il ya un balcon elle
était bourré je voulais dire et ça on a
des preuves et on a des preuves déjouer
ses plans de la formation oui d'accord
ce qu'on peut on va paraître un peu pour
tout préjudice moral préjudice d'image
diffamation la procédure est en cours
jouit depuis quinze jours puisque sur
les réseaux sociaux ça a été un
déferlement de haine mis d'accord et
c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui et jeudi
c'est clair et net c'est la première et
la dernière fois qu'on viendra
s'expliquer sur ce sujet là